well let's jump right in to
the finale i want to go all the way to
that last episode of season four yeah
you end the season
can we call it a frustrated freakout
uh i wouldn't say a freak out i mean a
lot led up to that moment that you know
was not shown you're late girl
well you know fashionable
all of us girls wanted to talk to you
and just kind of clear the air with
everything
okay well i'm
not we're not not in a bad way i'm i'm
so good we just don't want any more i'm
so good
i don't need like
you know
you guys okay forget it let's go let's
go come on
there was a lot that happened hours
before and you know
we all were there hours and hours and
hours before christine showed up and
you know i was going to take that time
to have like a really nice conversation
with her and just kind of clear the air
with a lot of things that have obviously
been spewing and you know he's she said
she said she said and so i just wanted
to clear the air in a nice calm way with
her and what people don't see is tark
and i were heading out to um st farts
that night on a red-eye and i had been
waiting around for christine for hours
she knew i was waiting around to talk to
her she decided to show up hours later
than all of us other girls were there
and i actually like left and decided to
come back because i knew she was going
to show up in about 10 minutes but i was
like already an hour passed when i was
supposed to leave
and they're like she's coming in 10
minutes and i said okay you know what i
just want to talk to her before i leave
on this vacation
and
you know she showed up and she kind of
brushed me off um i like i said i was
already stressing out the time she
disregarded the fact that we were all
waiting for her i was waiting for her
specifically she shows up i wanted to
have a nice conversation with her she
completely brushed me off and she's like
i'm good i'm good i'm i'm so good we
just don't want any more i'm so good i'm
like you know what if you're good i'm
good too she wanted to mend a friendship
with me in the relationship she showed
me she didn't care so i'm good i'm going
on my vacation with my future husband at
the time and you know so a lot had led
up to that frustration it wasn't like i
just had to freak out and laugh that
makes sense that fills in a big question
i had of why did it go from zero to 60
so fast it's because you were playing a
waiting game all day like um like
everything was calm everything was chill
i was like okay she's you know gonna be
on her way i'm gonna have a nice talk
with her and then it all just you know
all just happened very fast all at once
you and tark are kind of
flying out of there and emma yells from
the table love you
yeah
because the girls knew my frustration
right i love you
if you guys want to talk to me you can
talk to me that's fine i'll talk to her
privately she doesn't want that okay you
want to talk to me privately i have
nothing to say to her it's fine okay
let's go okay
he shows up three hours late she's
useless heather do you want to talk to
me privately you saw like after i left a
lot of the drama kept going
and as the girl said like heather just
wanted to have a nice sweet conversation
with you just to kind of clear the air
about a lot of frustrations that had
been happening and i didn't get that
chance and she's the one that had been
wanting that and then didn't give me the
opportunity i don't know i don't know
why you know i think maybe she thought
it was going to go into a negative
direction which i was not planning on it
going that direction i just honestly
wanted to have a nice talk with her
as you were leaving she did try and say
hey you want to talk one-on-one but i
guess your decision was made at that
point at that point i already felt
disrespected because i had been waiting
for three hours for her and then when
she brushed me off i was like you know
what i don't need to wait around and be
late and miss my flight to my on my trip
with my husband so at that point i was
just done she had disrespected me
already
this season you go as far as to say you
hate her
you tear up over it
you say she's making your life
unnecessarily stressful a lot of your
issues though played out off camera it
seems like so can you kind of fill in
those blanks for me of
all it's a lot of death by a thousand
paper cuts is what i'm picking up on it
wasn't one thing she did to you it was a
bunch of little things well
obviously yeah you know you only see so
much of our lives on camera right we all
have lives outside of camera and outside
of filming and it had been a lot of
things building up and her and i had not
had a close relationship for probably
over a year
um
and you know there's just a lot of
things that she had said and done to not
only me and my husband and talking and
and just things to my close friends that
i just at some point you can't keep
supporting someone and making excuses
for them and
in that specific moment she had brought
some things up on camera to the other
girls
and
you know had called some of the girls
off camera and said you know i'm gonna
drag heather into this
and i hope you have my back so there was
a lot of things that i didn't say on
camera and
um didn't you guys are not informed
about but she like basically dragged me
into her drama just to bring me into her
and emma's drama that is so irrelevant
in my life so at that point i'm like why
why are you doing this like why are you
bringing stuff up that is so far in the
past just to cause issues with me
let's get into that there is this entire
mutual x
situation between christine
and emma and then you get brought into
it we are working off of
at least two different timelines at
least two different sets of facts
who is telling the truth here
you're gonna have to ask emma and
christine about those facts i really
knew nothing about christine um it's
really irrelevant in my life i'm happily
married i don't care to talk about that
person he wasn't an ex it was a very
brief moment in my life that means
nothing so christine's trying to make a
bigger deal about everything and so you
know whatever she thinks her timeline is
okay but she makes up a lot of things so
i would fact check that with emma i
would assume you believe emma over
christine i don't believe a lot of
things christine says so um you know
like i said i don't know the timeline i
don't know the situation 100 but um i do
know that emma tells the truth
what do you need from christine to move
forward
um you know christina and i
can be professional at work we can be
cordial to each other i don't want to
have animosity and be fighting and be
catty all the time and have negative
energy but i just choose to not have her
in my life because i don't trust her as
a friend and loyalty to me is a huge
thing and you know friends are very
sacred to me and i don't use that word
lightly so right now you know we're not
friends i don't know if we can get back
to that place time will only tell and i
have to see her actions being very
consistent
give me a teaser for season five is
there forward movement backwards
movement no movement
i'd say there is definitely some forward
movement
okay that's positive i'm a very open
person you know i'm not
you know i've gone through different
emotions with with that situation with
christine and you see that kind of come
out like
i gave her a lot of chances a lot
happened off camera but
you know i'm not a mean person i'm a
nice person i have a big heart so we'll
have to see if um i can trust her and
believe the things she says moving
forward because right now i don't i she
you know she sends me text messages and
then
i have proof to say that those are lying
you know and the other girls they tell
me the truth and i hear from the eight
other girls are they all lying to me and
then this one person is the root of
everything is she the one telling the
truth that everybody else is lying i
don't think so
what do you make of her calling the rest
of you at the o group mean girls who
froze her out of the group
it's not true i mean there's one common
denominator i mean i think you've seen
enough of me to know i'm not a mean girl
i'm a very loving kind person and i'm a
girls girl i'm very supportive of all
the women at the o group we're all hard
working we're all driven we're all kind
and sweet and like i said there's one
person that no one gets along with so is
it all of us or is it that one person
i don't need to be treated like i'm a
student
she treats everybody like
like it's called karma you know
like i said there's a lot more tarik in
this season including that finale
as you guys are leaving the party
you're reminding him hey you're miked
there's a camera on you because this is
a different kind of reality show than he
is used to filming what were you afraid
of him saying or what were you trying to
protect him from um by reminding him of
that well you know at that time when we
left obviously i was very upset and he's
my husband he's comforting me and in
that moment when i was heated and upset
we did not actually know the cameras
were on us and then i turned around and
i saw that they were filming us so just
as a reminder to protect my husband i
said you know the camera's not if the
cameras are honest he is a very
you know strong-minded person and
um if he sees that his wife is upset
about something he's gonna support me a
hundred percent no matter what um as i
would do for him but it is a very
different show i don't want him involved
in the toxicity of the show that can
happen and the drama um he doesn't need
to be a part of that you know it's
girl's drama and it's just he needs to
stay away from that
so where do we pick up on things in
season five does the action i know you
aren't in the editing room piecing it
together but you know what you lived um
well the action pick up right where we
left off is there a time jump like from
the action you kind of see things
continue
and you see a lot more changes happen
with the group so
i think i think you see some people kind
of working on things
new friendships formed
um more drama but i think things are a
little bit on the mend and romance in
the office
yeah i could get jason and gracel yeah
very excited
it's insane to me i don't know what to
say i knew before they told me so weird
though but like exciting but like so
right i'm not getting into that you know
we're not criminals we're not doing
anything wrong
[Music]
the whole teaser we get at the end of
season four four season five is about
them and the shock that this was to the
office how has them becoming a couple
changed the dynamics at the office if at
all i don't think much i mean obviously
none of us knew for a very long time and
then when it did come out um
you know they're very professional at
the office they might like pack here and
there but they're very professional and
they're very cute together and it's
still like i mean not anymore but at
first i'd see them kiss and i'm like you
know and i love love so for me like if
he's happy and she's happy and they're
in love like i'm it just makes me
excited i i love to see people happy and
happy in their relationships i'm very
interested to see how that all plays out
on the show because we get little teases
in season four of like lingering eye
moments and i saw that
yelled at like moments of jealousy so
i'm it's i think it's gonna be fun to
see i think
coming to netflix
more
selling shows selling the oc
is i think soon to start filming
you live down in the oc you are listed
on the agent page for the newport office
are you going to uh switch shows
i am not going to switch the shows i'm
gonna stay with my original selling
sunset um
that's my family up there i've been
there at the you know office for
gosh over six years now and um
i do real estate down here as well but
that's still my real estate home up
there so maybe i'll pop in here and
there but we'll see that's up to jason
and the network and the producers
how do you feel about the university
expanding because we also learned this
week that
selling tampa is coming
yeah i'm excited to see it and see the
dynamics between the girls we all met
about a week and a half ago and they
were so sweet and so fun i didn't even
know there was like spin-off shows um
happening until like i think like a
month and a half ago so i was like oh my
god why what is it selling tampa so i
was in the dark about everything but i'm
excited to see it
you